[Music]
just like a sword
where you touch
already in his body
it's already
not be out of his body till you get the
grin
in his body
stop
you're not for those who know songkill
tell me how much sense it makes
you
have a pain
that makes him go out and wants to move
i see i can barely do it on this
teenager
[Music]
pain compliance
is very low percentage
i know you're not going to get me to do
anything out of pain and you're being
trained the same way okay
it's kind of like mikio
nikyo can be done as a wrist block
but it can be done in his body
we want in his body
so the same thing here it's in his body
the same it's not important
that it's open or closed
because it's wherever i touch
his body
oh why can't i be in his body with the
yonko grip
gotta
be in his body
[Music]
shhh
in other words
don't stress your mechanics
the more you stress your mechanics
i'm trying to go
the stronger i have to be there
you don't stress your mechanics
[Music]
your hair you're here in his body
you're just in his body
makes no sense to try to overpower
someone
it makes less martial sense
that you can generate enough pain
that they do what you want them to do
okay
being in their body
take their center
generate kazushi that is much more
marshally sound okay
so this is just a micro drill to teach
the grip and the concept
the aikido
conceptual thread not this locking the
locking overpowering
pain intimidation very much
impractical
and very much not aikido okay
you're gonna do it that way of course if
you can overpower someone
they're much weaker than you and you
intimidate them it works but that's low
fruit okay
um come back here dude
again read my intuition
be on garden ware okay
so sit square let us ask a couple
questions so we already said more
marshall to be in his body and to start
affecting his balance we already said
that okay
than to intimidate him into cowardice
well
we only have
certain kazushi angles in aikido kihon
wasa right
it's not going to be the rear ones so
it's going to be the front inward ones
do you got that he's either going to go
this way
or he's going to go this way
okay
that's what you're trying to do
so you're not trying to uh get him
into this pin do you see
you have to make his body
go
[Music]
not it
not different than this
your body's going to do the same thing
his body don't pay attention to his arm
because his arm does something different
but his body does that same
his body does that
same thing
then you'll have the peculiarities of
sankyo it's not as evident in this micro
drill but in its application
it is further in the circle
and lower
than equal
okay
so you don't want to bring this thing
way up here and way out here
okay
it's low
and tighter
don't watch him he's going to do the
same position
but if you watch my hands
much smaller circle
than eq
is much smaller
and lower
got it
okay
then just like ego don't start in his
body
and then come off his body
or never go in his body because you're
in front
you're coming around
this way and then you go here
stay in his body
[Music]
so
he even on the last part
he doesn't keep the center still like
this
he continues to fall
into the position and it's actually
when he tries to gain balance again
that he'll push into the structure
and the coke you sends him down okay
i didn't swing my arm down you see he's
hitting the structure
[Music]
this is why he falls in stages